des profs de ps2 blois voir où ils ont
été auditionnés par la direction
académique et de loir et cher pour avoir
fait classe dans un gymnase
c'était le 18 janvier dernier le jour de
la mise en oeuvre de l'interdiction des
pratiques sportives en intérieur les
quatre enseignants se défendent ils ont
juste fait asseoir leurs élèves à l'abri
en respectant les distances sanitaire la
direction académique y voit elle un acte
politique les profs manifesté ce matin
parmi les revendications la réouverture
des gymnases romain delville le premier
message de ses professeurs d'éducation
physique et sportive devant la
préfecture de blois c'est que les
gymnases de la ville sont leurs salles
de classe
s'il est possible de faire classe au
collège il est possible de faire sport
mais ça c'était avant le 18 janvier
désormais les cours de sport en
intérieur sont interdits j'étais en
pratique des escalades avec une classe
donc j'étais seul avec ma classe dans
dans une salle d' escalade à partir du
jour au lendemain on dit non vous avez
pu le droit d'y aller alors que
il n'y avait pas de brassage dans cette
salle j'étais on se demande pourquoi on
peut pas emmener notre vingtaine
d'élèves dans une salle couverte alors
que
on alors qu'on peut les mettre dans une
salle de classe ce rassemblement initié
par fo sud est supporté par des profs
d'autres matières par en fait de la
contestation d'une convocation de quatre
professeurs deux ps par la directrice
académique
leur tort avoir fait asseoir leur groupe
le lundi 18 janvier dans le gymnase de
ce collège
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi alors
qu'il ya aucune statistiques qui
prouvent que il ya plus de
contaminations qu'ailleurs en eps
pourquoi on ne propose pas une activité
physique par exemple
bien sûr en respectant les gestes
barrière en diminuant les effectifs mais
au moins qu'ils aient une continuité
dans les activités physiques
deux des quatre profs sont aujourd'hui
en arrêt maladie nous avons demandé une
interview à la direction des services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
qui n'a pas répondu à nos sollicitations